bien mes chers amis ça fait plaisir
effectivement d'autres l'ont dit avant
moi cette tribune de voir notre famille
rassemblée est prête à s'engager sur la
dernière ligne droite celle de
l'élection présidentielle alors vous
avez entendu tous les les commentaires
d'abord ceux qui ont voulu nous faire
croire que françois hollande en
renonçant à se présenter à l'élection
présidentielle avait pris une décision
courageuse qui méritait d'être d'être
saluée comme il se doit
la réalité c'est que tout simplement
c'est une reddition sans condition c'est
une vraie démission en rase campagne
d'ailleurs pouvait-il en faire autrement
et il l'a fait dans quelles conditions
il l'a fait sous les coups de poignard
d'un premier ministre qui porte
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs tout le poids de
sa trahison dans cette campagne des
primaires iso mes chers amis abîmer nos
institutions en allant jusqu'à nommer un
premier ministre qui est là pour cinq
mois pour avec pour seule mission de
fermer les lumières ou de tenter de
repeindre en rose un bilan qui est noir
pour la france et je voudrais dire un
mot à propos de monsieur cazeneuve il
faut pas oublier ce qu'il est il est
celui qui a laissé faire les nuits de
vous place de la république est un peu
partout en france
il est celui
et à laisser faire les actes odieux
contre l'hôpital necker
il est celui qui a mis à peine arrivée à
matignon un genou à terre devant les
anarchistes à notre dame des landes
il est celui qui a refusé avec dédain
avec mépris
toutes les propositions la plupart des
propositions que nous avons fait pour
lutter contre le terrorisme djihadiste
et ceux qui se termine aujourd'hui pour
les socialistes par une véritable
bérézina a commencé ne l'oublions pas
par les mensonges indigne à l'occasion
de la présidentielle les français y ont
cru et l'enjeu pour nous l'enjeu il est
aujourd'hui d'expliquer et de faire en
sorte que nos compatriotes entendre
comprennent et un vert un discours de
vérité et ce discours de vérité c'est le
tien françois c'est le discours que tu
portes aujourd'hui en notre nom
ce discours vous savez il va être
difficile à faire passer parce qu'il
faut l'assumer et pour cela nous avons
effectivement besoin que toute notre
famille soit rassemblée qu'elles soient
unis et ce conseil national et ce
symbole aujourd'hui quelques étés nos
choix aux primaires nous sommes unis
nous sommes rassemblés
nous sommes à tes côtés pour soi
le bilan de la gauche rappelons-le est
là aussi le bilan de la gauche c'est
d'abord un million cent cinquante mille
chômeurs toutes catégories confondues
de plus en quatre ans et demi c'est sale
en bilan c'est ensuite la bombe à
retardement du chômage des jeunes
et puis c'est aussi l'apprentissage qui
étaient sacrifiés nous l'avons souvent
évoquée à 7 à cette tribune l'oua est
souvent entendu défendre l'apprentissage
à 14 ans je continue à le défendre
ils ont sacrifié l'apprentissage sur
l'autel de leurs doctrines l'urgence
là aussi c'était dit c'est de
réhabiliter le travail et nous avons un
vrai dilemme avec la gauche sur le
travail
pour la gauche le travail est un mal
nécessaire
c'est une contrainte pour nous le
travail c'est un élément d'identité
c'est un élément d'intégration c'est un
épanouissement et c'est là-dessus qu'il
faut se battre
ce sont les valeurs de la droite c'est
le travail et sa reconnaissance
et pour cela il faudra faire sonner le
verrou des 35 heures
le faire sauter dans le privé le faire
sauter dans le public
la france continuera décliner ciel ne
travaille pas plus et ça ça fait aussi
partie du message de vérité que nous
devons avoir le bilan de la gauche si
aussi le déficit c'est aussi la dette
c'est aussi le matri cas le matraquage
systématique des classes moyennes la
surconcentration de l'impôt la baisse du
quotient familial la mise sous condition
de ressources des allocations familiales
la fiscalisation des complémentaires
santé on a tendance à oublier tout cela
il faut aussi le rappeler à l'occasion
de cette campagne le bilan de la gauche
c'est aussi la confiscation du fruit du
travail à coups de rsa de ses murs dames
deux tiers payant généralisé et si on ne
l'arrête pas avec le revenu universel
notre devoir demain en application de
ton projet france soir c'est de faire en
sorte de reconnaître et de récompenser
ceux qui travaillent ceux qui produisent
plus ceux qui enrichissent la france on
ne peut pas en un mot rendre toujours ou
même est donnée à ceux qui profitent du
système et il ne faut pas confondre
solidarité assistanat
la solidarité c'est une valeur de droite
la solidarité c'est noble
la solidarité c'est notre honneur
l'assistanat sa tante il lui saute
pardon l'assistanat ça nous conduit à
lécher à la déchéance et c'est nous
conduit à l'échec et nous devons nous
battre contre l'assistanat et valoriser
nos actions de solidarité le bilan de la
gauche c'est aussi la casse dans
l'éducation nationale
madame belkacem et ses acolytes peillon
et à monde alors ils auront moins record
je pense qu'ils resteront dans notre
république
comme les ministres qui ont fait qui ont
fait fuir le plus d'élèves du public
vers le privé des fora au moins le
reconnaître cela ils ont mené avec
méthode
une politique sectaire et dogmatique
dogmatique sur les rythmes scolaires
dogmatique sur la réforme du collège
sectaires sur les programmes notamment
en histoire où ils creusent un fossé
dangereux entre nos jeunes et l'histoire
de notre pays une histoire qu'il
réécrive si elle ne correspond pas à
leurs valeurs de gauche au moment
d'ailleurs où certains tata compte
heureusement françois parce que tu
aurais eu l'outrecuidance de revendiquer
chrétien est ce que l'on acceptera
longtemps de baisser les yeux et de
s'excuser d'être les produits d'une
civilisation judéo-chrétienne d'être les
enfants de l'esprit des lumières
il est temps de lever les yeux et de
relever la tête
d'avoir le courage d'assumer ce que nous
sommes et ce qu'est la france
enfin le bilan de la gauche ça n'est pas
le bilan de hollande c'est le bilan de
tous deux valses à matheron de
montebourg à sa fin de taubira cazeneuve
ils sont tous caution solidaire de ce
bilan
on ne va pas rappeler la sphère cahuzac
où les ministres qui est sont devenus
administrativement phobique et puis deux
expressions deux expressions qui ne faut
pas oublier les sens dans de françois
hollande et les ouvrières il les traits
de monsieur macron vous savez ces deux
expressions elles en disent beaucoup
plus long que n'importe quel discours
sur ce que la gauche pense réellement du
peuple
je ne reviens pas sur le scooter d'un
président complètement inconsciente ces
comportements sur madmoizelle leonarda
sur le socle est secret défense
donner en pâture aux journalistes le
temps de l'alternance approche le temps
de la rupture profonde
le temps d'un changement qui permettra à
nouveau à la france d'être vraiment
présider et d'être vraiment gouverner
cette france ce seront celles de la
présidence de françois fillon
nous devons aujourd'hui avec lui autour
de lui travail il toutes nos forces pour
le porter à l'elysée et pour lui offrir
une majorité forte avec un groupe de
parlementaires issus des républicains un
groupe qui aura la majorité absolue
parce que mes chers amis
moi j'aime tout le monde on accepte tous
les soutiens mais un moment si vous le
nous voulons conduire une politique
claire nette sans ambiguïté il faut le
faire sur nos sols notre stock et donc
il faut avoir la majorité absolue
chez les républicains ceux qui veulent
nous rejoindre sur les bienvenus mais
c'est nous qui porteront le projet et
c'est à nous d'avoir la majorité absolue
sonnent les républicains doivent l'avoir
et c'est de cette façon mon cher
françois que nous mettrons en oeuvre son
projet avec détermination avec courage
et sans problème vive la france vive la
république
[Applaudissements]